HéHélène Buzzetti, Luc Fernande,
ChChristian Dufour, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Officiellement, il ne va pas
rerenouveler son mandat, on va
écécouter Monsieur Legault sur a
nonotion d'imputabilité et on
rerevient.
- - Ce que je comprends
dudu rapportrt, c'est qu'il y a
bebeaucoup de choses qui se sont
papassées après que le CIUSSS
a a pris le contrôle du CHSLD.
DoDonc, c'est pas l'information
quque j'avais.
CÇa doit être plus clair
ququ'il faut être imputable
dede ce qu'on s'occupe, mais...
lele premier ministre, puis même
lele ministre de la Santé
pepeut pas commencer à s'assurer
dede gérer ce qu'il l se passe
dadans chacun des établissements
dede santé au Québec, là.
DoDonc, c'est pour ça qu'il faut
ququ'il y ait une délégation
dede pouvoir, puis quand quelqun
ggère pas bien, eh bien,
ilil faut changer le gestionnai.
- - Il faut changer le
gegestionnaire.
ChChristian j'avais commencé avc
vovous, souvent vous dites avece
rarapport, jamais rien ça, voici
quque la coronaire, et encore ue
fofois, Madame McVey n'est pas
l'l'coupable de ce rapport là,
mamais la désorganisation du
SuSuisse de l'Ouest et montrer u
dodoigt.
QuQu'est-ce que vous pensez de a
dédécision de partir?
- - Je trouve qu'il y a au moins
unun minimum d'imputabilité par
rarapport à cette catastrophe l.
OnOn est dans un régime
paparlementaire, quand des drams
cocomme ça arrive, semble-t-il l
y y avait la responsabilité
miministérielle, même si le
miministre n'était pas en soi
reresponsable de ce qui arrive
dadans son ministère, ça me déçt
bebeaucoup dans ce rapport, qu'l
nene soit pas du tout assumer ds
reresponsabilités.
C'C'est une régression politiqu.
JeJe trouve que Monsieur Legault
sesentir bien, ce monde-là qui
n'n'était pas suffisamment
cocompétent, c'est quand même sn
gogouvernement qui était là.
- - Luc, qu'est-ce qu'elles de
pepensée et de la nouvelle
auaujourd'hui et aller plus
lalargement sur ce rapport,
ChChristian le souligne sa
pepension, on croyait que Madame
CaCamel allait être plus dure
enentre guillemets, ce n'est pas
lele cas.
- - Et la chercher ceux des
sosolutions, il faut séparer la
cacapacité opérationnelle
ststratégique, c'est-à-dire quad
l'l'État donne un ordre il ne pt
papas être en même temps celui i
vévérifie que l'ordre a été fai.
MaMais, je trouve que c'est très
prpratique de Monsieur Legault e
paparler de cette
dédécentralisation. Il faut que
l'l'essayer que la bureaucratie
susur le noyau possible.
CeCeci étant dit, c'est un
prproblème de ressources humain.
LeLes problèmes de ressources
humamaines sont gérés par des
coconversions collectives, gérés
papar des ressources conférées r
l'l'État.
LeLe salaire des préposés aux
bébénéficiaires et fixe, même
chchose pour les infirmières, me
chchose pour les ententes avec s
mémédecins, qu'est-ce qui resteà
gégérer sur le terrain.
LeLes horaires aussi sont assez
fifixes.
IlIl ne reste pas tant de marge
popour les responsabilités.
JeJe trouve que c'est très
prpratique comme discours pour
MoMonsieur Legault.
- - Hélène?
- - Je suis assez d'accord que
MoMonsieur Legault et son équipe
sesentait assez bien.
CeCeci dit, même si le principe
d'd'imputabilité ministérielle
dodont Christian parlait est asz
imimportant, ce ministère de la
sasanté est tellement gigantesqe
s's'il n'y avait qu'un seul
fufusible d'imputabilité, c'est-
didire le ministre, le ministree
lala santé ne resterait pas
sosouvent en palace, la machine
esest tellement grosse.
J'J'émettrais ce bémol-là.
DeDe manière générale, j'avoue e
lele rapport final de la coronae
m'm'a un peu réconcilié avec le
prprocessus.
CÇa m'agace un petit peu,
pepersonnellement, cette démarc.
ApAprès coup, maintenant qu'on
sasait ce qui est arrivé, qu'on
coconnaît la pandémie, qu'on
coconnaît comment le papyrus tot
cocomportait.
IlIl y a quelque chose de facile
dede retourner en arrière.
IlIl y avait quelque chose d'un
pepeu agaçant là-dedans.
JeJe trouve que la coronaire à
évéviter cet écueil de la en étd
plplus posée dans la répartition
dudu blanc.
- - On voit qu'elle a écouté qud
mmême de monde. Elle avait un
poportrait général.
MoMonsieur Legault, on reste avc
MoMonsieur Legault, on a vu avec
lala manifestation de certaines
pepersonnes anglophones, et
d'd'autres, contre les projets e
loloi 96, Monsieur Legault avait
cece message à la communauté
ananglophone.
PRPRINCE CHARLES, Son Altessee
- - Puis il y a aussi de
lala désinformation concernant
leles services de santé, parce e
lala loi 96 ne change absolument
ririen sur l'obligation qu'on a
cocomme gouvernement de donner
dedes services en anglais même x
nonouveaux arrivants qui parlent
jujuste anglais. Donc il n'y a
ririen de changé de ce côté-là.
EtEt puis dans les cégeps,
bibien, comme je l le disais,
leles anglophones représentent
9 9 % de la population, 17 %
dedes places; et puis c'est préu
dadans le projet de loi 96 que s
ananglophones vont avoir priorié
popour ces places-là.
- - Alors, il a voulu rassurer a
cocommunauté anglophone, a-t-il
mamarqué des points.
- - On disait mon Dieu, on ne
popourra plus se faire soigner,t
mmême certains évoquaient la
popossibilité que des inspecteus
pupuissent invoquer des médecins
ququi puissent parler français à
leleurs clients.
IlIl y a une minoritaire agissat
dudu côté des anglophones qui
ffêtent des pressions comme pour
lala loi 101 pour indiquer toute
prprogression du français va nos
éléliminer.
ToToute progression du françaist
ininjustifié.
FaFaire paraître le gouvernement
LeLegault comme un monstre la
mamatière.
EÉvidemment, ça va durer pendant
dedes années.
ToTout renforcement des lois au
QuQuébec, la loi 96 va l'être tt
auautant.
- - Christian, il a expliqué
popourquoi il n'allait pas
paparticiper aux débats
ananglophones lors de la prochae
cacampagne, en disant que un,
sasalut mangé trop de temps, et
quque deux, la langue française
esest la langue officielle, qu'n
pepensez-vous?
- - Sur cette position-là, par
rarapport aux autres qui ont
tetendance à dire que l'anglais
esest assez important, c'est
ququelqu'un qui n'est pas
tototalement à l'aise en anglai.
JeJe ne sais pas.
JeJe vais juste revenir sur le
drdroit linguistique, je pense e
LuLuc a raison, quand on toucheà
lala longue, un peu controversé.
CeCe n'est pas un échec pour
MoMonsieur Legault, il aurait bn
vovoulu que tout ça se passe en
cocontroverse, avec un consensu.
IlIl est arrivé ce que je
crcraignais.
EnEn refusant de faire preuve un
pepeu d'audace, d'appliquer la i
10101 au cégep, claire et simpl.
IlIl s'est enlisé dans le
TaTataouine âge.
LaLa prédominance du français, s
dedeux tiers, il a enlisisé dans
ququelque chose où elle est
peperdant.
JeJe trouve qu'il paye le prix,
seserre a été un peu plus
sisimple,... s'il avait fait ça,
ilil y aurait eu controverse, il
nene serait pas aussi enlisé qul
esest actuellement.
Il v voulait éviter la
cocontroverse, et pourtant il l.
- - Hélène, on va revenir à ça,
HéHélène de manière générale,
cocomment vous voyez cette
rerelation entre le communauté
ananglophone et la CAQ, est-ce e
MoMonsieur Legault a du chemin
popour rassurer les gens?
- - Oui.
ViVisiblement, on ne lui fait ps
coconfiance.
SaSans vouloir sembler cynique,l
y y a peut-être un avantage aux
papartisans. Qui a l'avantage de
nunuire au Parti libéral, qui
sosoudainement, se fait menacer
papar ses deux autres parties
ananglophones prévenir lui grugr
soson vote.
IlIl semble être le nationalisme
dudu groupe, se porter à la
dédéfense de la majorité
frfrancophone, ça pourrait êtreu
ququand même positivement par ue
mamajorité.
JeJe pense que d'un point de vue
ststrictement calcul politique,
pepeut-être qu'il cogne quelque
chchose de cette situation mêmei
auau niveau de la paix sociale,
c'c'est certainement pas une boe
chchose.
- - Sans aller,... ce qu'il a dt
unun peu plus tôt, je suis l'moi
dudu milieu, qu'on émette pas le
nonombre de places dans les cégp
ananglophone, ce qui Christian
vovous disiez, on ferme l'accès
auaux francophones et aux
alallophones au cégep anglophon.
IlIl dit moi je suis au milieu s
plplaces actuelles on les garde,
mamais pas plus, pas moins.
- - Si vous permettez.
OnOn n'a pas besoin de ce genree
dédébat, strictement partisans,
pepeut-être qu'il gagne... il
n'n'avait parlant besoin de ça,e
pepense que ça aurait été meillr
popour tout le monde que ça se
fafasse plus de façon
coconsensuelle, pas consensuel,
mamais la manifestation
amamphétamine, il y a beaucoup e
dédémagogie, ce n'est pas
nénécessaire.
- - Ce n'est pas cependant, si n
jejeune francophone veut aller à
DaDalacine, qui par ailleurs, un
frfrançais impeccable, qui veutn
amaméliorer son anglais, ce n'et
papas cependant de lui dire non-
LeLequel?
- - Quand on regarde collectif,u
t't'aperçois que le poids du cép
dadans une, des cégep anglophon,
c'c'est 50 % pour une population
ququi en représente pas un
cicinquième.
CÇa ne marche pas, ça ne
fofonctionne pas.
LeLe problème de la loi 96, sa i
sasans solution.
CÇa ne va pas améliorer le fier
frfrançais au Québec.
LeLe fier français est menacé au
QuQuébec par bien plus que le fu
cécégep.
ElElle est menacée par... c'esta
lalangue de de l'anglais, du
didivertissement, des médias.
LeLes mesures sont prises, c'est
unune accumulation de petite
memesure qui n'arrivera pas à
chchanger cet état de fait.
- - Parlant de la langue, il y a
unun texte sur notre site qui a
sosorti des chiffres par rapport
auau sous-ministre anglophone, t
8080 % des sous-ministre sont...
enenfin plus on monte, moins ily
a a de francophone.
- - Oui.
CeCeci dit, il faut quand même
prpréciser que les sous-ministre
sosont tout ce plus ou moins
bibilingue.
SuSurtout leur origine
lilinguistique qui compte.
EfEffectivement.
Je suis presque étonné de ces
ininformations.
J'J'habite ici, dans la région
OtOttawa, Gatineau.
S'S'il y a une chose que tous ms
amamis fonctionnaires me dit
totoujours, c'est que la fonctin
pupublique canadienne elle n'est
papas bilingue, c'est une fonctn
pupublique qui est traduite.
LeLes choses se passent en
ananglais, et ensuite on traduit
leles mots pour donner cette
fafaçade de bilinguisme.
J'J'ai des amis fonctionnaires i
papar exemple, un nouveau
prprogramme est mis en oeuvre en
fafait des séances d'information
popour l'être expliqué au
trtravailleur, et même les
frfrancophones s'inscrivent aux
séséances anglaises parce que
c'c'est la qu'ils vont apprendre
lele vocabulaire lié à cette
popolitique.
SaSachant que tout va se passern
ananglais dans le futur il vint
mimieux apprendre en anglais.
- - On est en dessous du nombre
dédémographique.
- - Sachez que les anglophones,
eueux, critiquent constamment
l'l'inverse.
DaDans le reste de la fonction
pupublique, il y a 31 % de
frfrancophone ce qui est beaucop
plplus que le nombre de
frfrancophones au Canada.
- - J'ai appris vraiment des
chchoses, j'en suis parvenu 80 %
dedes fonctionnaires fédéraux st
frfrancophones.
2828 % des cadres sont
CÇa fait ressortir le fait que u
niniveau le plus élevé, on est n
babas du pourcentage qui serait
rerequis.
- - Vous dites que le portrait t
plplutôt bon.
- - Comme le dit Hélène, la sou-
miministre, ils sont bilingues.
IlIl y a des normes...
- - Je veux que vous me parliezu
prprince Charles, c'est pour ça
quque je vous presse.
LuLuc, comment avez-vous, on vot
dedes images.
IlIl a même écouté une bière avc
dede l'eau de l'iceberg. Accueii
papar le premier ministre,
l'l'gouverneur général. Alors, a
vovous inspire quoi, Luc, Hélèn,
etet Christian?
- - La monarchie n'a aucun effet
susur le Canada, il est tellemet
ininsignifiant, si peu
sisignificatif, il a très peu
d'd'impact sur nos vies.
OnOn le tolère.
ApAprès le décès de la reine
EÉlisabeth II, il y a le deux
titiers des pays du Commonwealt,
popourquoi nous on reste.
MyMystère et boule de gomme,
j'j'entends pas les Canadiens
rerevendiqués la monarchie.
JeJe n'entends pas une culture e
lala monarchie, ou des valeurs e
lala monarchie au Canada.
CÇa n'existe pas.
- - Je vais vous donner des
chchiens, je donne la parole à
HéHélène.
EsEst-ce que le Canada devrait
rerester une monarchie
coconditionnelle?
DaDans tout le Canada, 26 % oui,
QuQuébec 11 %, c'est assez clair
auau Québec.
HéHélène?
- - Il n'y a pas tant de mystèrs
etet boule de gomme. La raison
popour laquelle on s'en débarrae
papas, par ce que effectivement
elelle n'est pas très effective.
C'C'est parce qu'il s'est coincé
dadans notre constitution.
PoPour changer la structure
gogouvernementale, il faudrait
l'l'appui de 10 provinces, le
SéSénat, et la Chambre des
cocommunes.
C'C'est toujours, quand commencà
paparler de constitution, tout e
momonde arririve à la table aves
prpropres demandes,
rerevendications.
C'C'est pour ça que ça n'avance
papas.
OnOn ne peut pas juste avec un
clclaquement de doigt de dire qe
çaça disparaît.
MMême si ça n'a pas d'impact das
nonotre vie quotidienne, toutes
nonos lois, nos structures, sont
foformés de moyens tels.Qu'on a
bebesoin d'un sanctionnant, ce
fofonctionnaire là, c'est
l'l'gouverneur général.
- - C'est le chef d'État.
IlIl faut changer la caution,
dedevenir une république.
ChChristian, où en êtes-vous
dedevant la monarchie?
- - Je suis un d'seul Québécois
ququi a une certaine sympathie
popour la monarchie britannique.
CoComme le dit Hélène, en fait,
c'c'est difficile de changer ça.
C'C'est un débat très divisé fa.
LaLa majorité des Canadiens
vovoudrait qu'on passe pour aute
chchose, mais il y a une manière
étété... puisqu'on est au niveau
dedes symboles, je préfère un
prprince Charles qui parle biena
lalangue maternelle. La reine
d'd'Angleterre parle avec les
acactionnaires français.
C'C'est quelque chose qui me
totouche comme telle.
AuAux institutions politiques
brbritanniques, parlementarisme,
auau Québec, je peux comprendreà
cacause de la conquête, la
coconquête a un côté oppressant
ququi est encore là à certains
égégards.
CÇa va aider le pouvoir
ququébécois, ça été le pouvoir
frfrancophone et la reine
d'd'Angleterre je trouve c'est e
grgrande dame.
- - D'autant que techniquement,
cocomme le dit Hélène, ce n'est
papas si simple à remplacer.
LuLuc, ce n'est pas si simple, i
ilil faut trouver un système qui
vava fonctionner.
- - Oui, d'accord.
MaMais des changements
coconditionnels, au prochain
chchangement conditionnel, est-e
ququ'on prêt le mètre en paralle
avavec le prochain changement
coconstitutionnel.
- - À une prochaine ronde
coconditionnelle, je ne sais pas
ququand.
- - On peut rêver.
(r(rires)
- - Merci au revoi